hello and welcome today we're looking at
the odds are all a statistical test for
detecting adversarial examples so
shameless self-promotion here since this
is me yep so this is an archive and
basically what we do is we're detecting
adversarial examples for those who don't
know what an adversarial example is it's
basically a a way of fooling a
classifier in in order to kind of get it
to do something weird let's look at it
so maybe you have an image of a cat and
I have no cat whoops all right so we
have an image of a cat and you have a
classifier all right so the classifier
takes this image as an input kind of
winds it down to some probabilities of
classes and capped dog and so on and it
then gives you an estimate of how likely
each class is and so on
so what an adversary example does is it
changes this this image and it adds a
noise so this is just a very specific
noise and you have kind of a multiplier
here gamma which is super small so the
noise is almost you can't see it by with
a human eye basically it's so small but
it's it's able to perturb this image in
a way that the the probabilities will
change such that all of a sudden a
different class now is the highest class
so basically we're able to fool these
classifiers by adding just very little
bit of very very specific noise so
that's an adversarial example these are
many implications in let's say security
applications and also in understanding
how these classifier works all right so
our task is to explain and
them explain why they happen and detect
detect when they happen all right so
what is what what do we do right
basically let's let's just jump right
into into the into the same here we view
a classifier as an output yes sir you
have log it's what's called log it's L e
is this it's this here is your neural
network up to the last layer basically
it can be like something like a
convolutional neural network and so on
it gives you a feature representation so
you extract from the image X a feature
representation which is this entire
thing here and then you multiply this
feature representation so there's going
to be some vector of dimension D you
multiply this by this weight matrix
which is going to be something like okay
I've drawn it in the in the wrong
direction here let's draw W over here
it's called it's going to be D by let's
say K where K is the number of classes
okay still wrong D by K right and output
a vector of dimension K which then is
this cat dog and so on so these are
these are the law gates and the log it's
get transformed to the probabilities by
running it through a softmax layer but
basically we view a classifier as having
a feature representation and a weight
matrix and this here is that is a is a
matrix multiplication a dot product by
matrix so what we what we see basically
is
this is this is kind of where that where
several examples happen so when we look
at this weight matrix right again we
look at the D dimensional feature vector
here and we look at the weight matrix
what it does is it has columns right
columns let's say we we have four
classes here right so it has these four
columns and each of them is d
dimensional so each of them is going to
be multiplied by this thing and giving a
score so the final score for a class is
going to be the multiplication of a row
W 1 W 2 W 3 w 4 by this feature vector
let's call the feature vector little F
right so your your log it of class I is
going to be the inner product of W I and
F all right we'll leave away biases for
now there's there's okay we can
introduce biases to make it a bit more
complicated but it changes nothing so
your log it's going to be the inner
product and whichever log it is the
highest wins that so that's going to be
the prediction of the classifier so
since eat since you can in an
adversarial example what can you change
you can change this feature vector here
this F by changing the X you can change
the output of the of the convolutional
neural network which is the feature
vector and what do you have to do in
order to make a law get as high as
possible basically me make one class as
high as possible
is you need to make this inner product
as high as possible
and what's an inner product if you're
looking at in like a classic vector
representation space if this is W I and
this is F what you want to do
if you wanna make F and W a line as much
as possible because the inner product is
going to be basically dependent on the
angle and the magnitude so you can even
stretch F for sure but it's going to be
kind of aligned with all the top views
then more by stretching or more
negatively in whatever one you want but
basically you want to rotate you want to
align as much as possible the F with the
WI so you want to kind of go into this
direction with F so now not only do you
want to kind of maximize F with a
particular WI what you want to do is be
adversarial the adversarial task is
often framed as just it's either
targeted and so find so I needs to be a
particular other class or it's
untargeted which means just just give me
a perturbation that will make the
classifier be fooled and be fooled means
whatever it predicts right now it should
predict something different right so
what you ultimately want to do is you
want this as high as possible for some I
that is not the correct I and you want
sorry you want this other quantity W Y
let's call it W y if let's say the
classifier is 100% correct so WI Y is
the label of X right and WI is whatever
column here current is currently
predicted so you want the some column
where I is not equal to Y to have
maximum inner product and so this is not
no longer hell I forget that they have
maximum inner product and you want this
to you want this inner product with the
correct class to be as
as possible which ultimately means you
want this entire quantity maximized so
it's a pretty simple idea we're called
let's say this is the log at I minus the
log it why we have slightly different
notation in the in the paper I think we
call this Z but never mind so you
basically just want to make this as as
large as possible and so our point is
since since your it's not the only thing
you want to maximize this but you have a
constraint namely your constraint is
that your Delta X can only be small
right your Delta X can only be small
because the point of an adversarial
example is that the perturbation is so
small you can't see it and that means
that you basically don't have much
wiggle room to do these to do these
perturbations which means that we should
be able to detect a pattern like this in
the latent space so this this here is
the latent space feature vector and if
we can kind of detect a pattern in the
latent space then we kind of get that
verse Ariel example detector alright so
how do we do this we measure exactly
this what we do is we measure the
alignment between the original between
the currently predicted class and
between all other classes so in this
graphic here you see this it's a 10
class classifier this is C for 10 we
only show one two three four we only
show six of the other classes but we
have the default graphic yeah in this so
this shows an adversarial example the
axis going on top of each of the images
is the alignment
with the adversarial class so this has
been an adversary perturbed sample so
this shows the alignment with the
adversarial class and of course you see
the bright red dot if you just focus on
that
that is the adversarial example right
projected into into this so of course
the alignment is going to be very very
high with this class since the
classifier actually predicts this class
the blue here is the sample that the
adversarial sample was derived from
which means the original image Canada
and you already see without looking at
any of the other dots that the blue is
around zero here around zero here and
zero here here and here but here it's
very high in this axis so the access to
the right is for each of these for each
of these plots here it's one of the
other classes except for the the
currently predicted adversarial class so
that this axis is always the same axis
and while the access to the right for
each plot is a different one and you can
already see then that's why we frame it
in the green the this this plot here is
where the access to the right
corresponds to the original class of the
classifier right so don't look yet at
the other thoughts what you see here is
basically the blue is is really high in
this class right and the adversarial
example procedure basically has driven
it down this class and up this class
which is exactly saying it has hid this
inner product small and this inner
product large so where do we go from
here let's actually jump this graphic a
bit and go to this one that's way down
here all right so what we've done is
we've taken
the an example just out of the dataset
right and then we've taken an
adversarial example so say X is the
example of the dataset and then X hat is
the adversarial example derived from
this all right in this plot to the right
X would be sitting about here and I'm
explaining what the what the kind of
meaning is and X hat would be sitting
down here right it's about one third
from the top one third from the bottom
let me draw this more alright so what
this X is represent here is basically
what we've done is we've gone from X to
X hat in very small steps and at each
step we've asked the classifier a
classifier what's the probability of the
class y so Y is the class of X right and
the class of X X hat is some some
different was some other class right
since it's an adversarial example we've
got so we've asked the classifier what's
the class of X and basic know basically
we've asked what what's the probability
that y is the class of X and that's
represented in white right so the more
white the higher the classifier thinks
the class Y is probable so the direction
down is going into the direction of X
hat minus X so it's going into the into
the adversarial direction and then the
direction across is we've taken some
direction that's orthogonal to this
direction and then also went into tiny
steps and that's the class farik
what do you think is the probability of
Y here so we've basically done this kind
of grid sampling and at each point we've
asked a classifier what do you think
which how probable is y and the
classifier will always output some
number and we plot it in white and so
did this direction again it's always the
same in this direction
we basically randomized it and then
aggregate it over over lots and lots of
different samples and we also aggregate
this entire thing over the entire over
the dataset so we get a comprehensive
view of what adversarial examples look
like in the view of the classifier and
what we find is pretty interesting so
when you go from the original class you
basically in every direction here in
every direction it kind of that the
original class kind of decreases
smoothly right you see at the edges here
it kind of gets black so the further
away you go from the original example
the more um a kind of shadier
the classifier units is like yeah I'm
not so sure anymore that this is the
class all right but if you go into the
direction of here if you go into the
direction of the adversarial example the
kind of drop-off is first of all it's
very steep so all of a sudden here
you're in very dark territory which
means the classifier that is doesn't
think Y is probable at all anymore and
moreover you get this kind of cone here
so what we see is what we what we think
is happening is that given a an example
there are these directions and laid in
in an image space basically straight
directions that go to adversarial
examples right and we call these cones
because they are kind of low dimensional
directions
in the space where the adversarial
example lies and what's really
interesting is we have some thoughts
here do we have more so what's what's
quite interesting is that ah here if you
if you go come on
well this is kind of okay the quality of
the of the plots is not it's not very
very good so I'm gonna I may be able to
to draw this here so if your start here
and you go here what happens to the
original class is you start out high you
go down rapidly and you stay down even
if you go super far into this direction
the this class will stay down whereas
let's say this is y hat Y hat will start
low go up and then can't fade so here is
where the adversarial example would sit
sorry at about this distance that's this
distance here means as you go towards
the adversarial example right here the
probability of the adversarial class
Rises and the probability of the
original class drops then as you go
further this is what's what's
interesting kind of this probability
here drops which means the classifier is
kind of like yeah okay there's too much
noise now I'm not so sure about this
class anymore but this this class here
kind of stays low very very long even if
you go into this direction so this gives
us kind of a that adversarial examples
are characterized by specific directions
that you go into that you can go into
and kind of suppress the original class
and pump the new class up which is kind
of exactly what we've claimed with this
inner inner product alignment right the
next experiments we've done is we've
taken this adversarial example here and
said well if we go outside if we go into
random directions right it's just really
this one direction that's problematic if
we go into random directions actually we
should be you know go back to the
original class right since it's
basically surrounded by the original
class this is just one direction and DC
represents all the other directions
there are and how many directions are
there in in pixel space like a lot so we
should be able to get back to the
original class but that's not the case
now that's we found that's not the case
and we also found why so still want to
go back to this plot here if you do this
if you add noise and this is the noise
magnitude here what you'll see is the
orange here is the adversarial class so
orange will go down right as you
increase the noise the blue is the
source class so the blue goes up and it
goes up faster because you see it goes
up faster than the green which is the
highest other class a green is whatever
class is not that reserved
not the source of the highest class
other than that so this source class
goes up quickly but before the source
class can overpass the adversarial class
which happens back there the highest
other class is already kind of taken
over so the source class is basically
two week and if you again look at this
this plot here if you go with an actual
color picker you see that the amount of
white
here and here is it's not high enough
it's like 0.3 or something out of one or
even lower so the the kind of source
class is not strong enough that by
simply adding a bit of noise you can go
back but we thought hey if this is
correct
we can actually detect it we can detect
this effect here this rising of the
source class faster so our plan is
basically we add noise particular amount
of noise just a little bit actually
and then we detect which basically which
class Falls in which class Rises and the
way we do this is we we detect the this
exact alignment that I've described the
for under noise so we form this quantity
here for all classes other than Y so Y
is the class it's currently predicted
and we look at it what happens under it
under noise right so and that's where we
get to this graphic here so again this
axis is the adversarial class or the
class is currently predicted right this
axis here is all the other classes for
each plot one and when we add noise what
do you see is the noise magnitude is
encoded in the brightness of the dots so
the darker the red dots the more noise
we've added here is the original
adversarial sample then as we add no ECC
here here more noise more noise more
noise it did nothing's really happening
for the for the if if if it's like one
class that has nothing to do with the
original class it simply kind of goes
down
simply kind of gets less sure about this
class right but in case of the original
class that that reserved example was
derived from it really Rises it really
kind of at the same time that it drops
it Rises into that direction so we're
able to measure these these deltas here
under noise and we're able to to device
basically statistics of what happens to
these quantities under like if it's not
an adversarial sample versus what
happens to these quantities if it's an
adversarial sample so here you see
pairings of basically source class an
adversarial class samples so each of
these histograms is collected from that
and what you can see is in blue the kind
of alignments under noise of the source
class sorry the alignments under noise
of a non perturbed sample and in orange
the alignments under noise of an
adversarial sample and what's cool is
that these these alignments you can see
in all of these cases are very different
so there is a clear signature in the
adversarial sample in these noise
induced alignments with the with the
weight matrix rows that makes you able
to basically build a detector you can
say alright anything to the left is
clean anything to the right is
adversarial and we can do this over many
different types of noises and then build
basically a voting mechanism on that and
thereby detect adversarial examples so
we have a bunch of experiments we mostly
experiment on the c4 ten and on the
imagenet data set and you can see over
here so this is the main kind of one of
the main results the detection rates of
our statistical test so as you can see
with our detection rate this is unclean
samples some clean samples you want the
detection rate to be low on adversarial
samples you want the tax rate to be high
and this we achieve very large detection
rates while having very low false
positive rates especially on imagenet so
it seems like the more tuned these
models are the better the smaller the
better we are at detecting and restore
examples to it it's kind of a direct
correlation to how well the models
perform on accuracy and in a clean
setting and what we can do is now since
we can not only detect these things but
we can detect these things in a fashion
so if if you look at these things and
you have like a sample of a particular
class that's predicted all right let's
say this class and you go and look at it
at the position of the noise-induced
features over each of them so let's say
here here here here here here here here
right
you can then clearly say well not only
do I detect an adversarial example here
right I look at the I look at each of
the class of the classes that it could
be derived from right if all if all of
them say it's a clean sample then all
right it's a clean sample but if one of
them says it's an adversarial sample
then I don't not only do I know it's an
adversarial sample but I say AHA this
must be the source class right this is
exactly fact we saw here all right we
can if we detect this pattern here we
can also back deduce basically aha so
this must be the original class that the
adversarial example was derived from so
we're basically able to build a not only
detector but we're basically able to
reconstruct the original class and here
you see for these models
let's say uncie for 10 we imagine that
is a bit too large as if you opt for for
our compute but on all these models that
have clean accuracies that are pretty
high on c for 10 plus this this kind of
toy network here we're able to
reconstruct the original class so
basically this is defense against
adversarial examples by by getting to
almost clean accuracy back so this is
really surprising actually and kind of
nice so we we do a bunch of other
experiments including we defend against
an attacker that's actually aware of
this thing but the main the main point
here is we don't say this is kind of the
end-all method of defending against
adversarial examples we simply want to
kind of encourage the way of thinking of
these kind of noise what what if you
what if you noise induce perturbations
how does your network react to that can
you can you detect these effects here
can you detect effects like this and are
these unavoidable or are there
architectures are there architectures we
can basically build such that
adversarial examples have no chance
except doing something like this which
we can then easily detect all right so
that was a bit of an introduction if you
would like check out the entire paper
and goodbye